en esta ocasión vamos a resolver la
ecuación 6 entre x cuadrada menos 5
entre x igual a 1 y para que sea más
fácil primero vamos a deshacernos de las
fracciones para eso solo tenemos que
observar los denominadores y vamos a
tomar el mínimo común múltiplo de los
dos
en este caso el mínimo común múltiplo de
x y x cuadrada es x cuadrada entonces
vamos a multiplicar ambos lados de la
ecuación por x cuadrada
si tenemos 6 / x cuadrada menos 5 entre
x igual a 1 y multiplicamos ambos lados
de la igualdad por x cuadrada al
multiplicar por la primera fracción x
cuadrada se cancela y nos queda 6 y en
la segunda fracción menos 5 x cuadrada
entre x es igual a menos 5 x
y eso es igual a equis cuadrada y miren
esta es una ecuación cuadrática tenemos
65 x igual a x cuadrada y recuerden que
en las ecuaciones cuadráticas es más
fácil resolverlas cuando acomodamos todo
para que sea igual a cero entonces en
este caso supongamos que el lado
izquierdo es igual a cero por lo tanto
nos queda que cero es igual a equis
cuadrada más 5 x menos 6 y ahora vamos a
factorizar esto como x 6 por x 1 y
después suponiendo que cada factor fuera
igual a cero podríamos decir que x 6 es
igual a 0 por lo tanto x puede ser igual
a menos 6 y si x menos uno es igual a
cero nos da la solución x igual a 1 y
esto es en lo que debemos de tener
cuidado cuando resolvemos ecuaciones
racionales
en la ecuación original tenemos que
sustituir las soluciones que encontramos
y asegurarnos de que no estemos
dividiendo entre cero
en este caso observen que si sustituimos
x igual a menos 6 en cada fracción no
nos da igual a 0 y lo mismo ocurre si
sustituimos x igual a 1 así que no hay
problema estas son nuestras soluciones
menos 6 y 1 ok
pasemos al siguiente 2 entre x + 2 + 2
entre x 4 igual a 1 bueno en este caso
nuestro mínimo común múltiplo es x + 2
por x 4 entonces
multipliquemos ambos lados de la
ecuación por eso
multipliquemos el lado izquierdo por x 2
x x menos 4 y también vamos a
multiplicar el lado derecho por x 2 x x
menos 4 entonces al multiplicar por la
primera fracción x + 2 se cancela y nos
queda
por x 4 más vamos a ver al multiplicar
x2 x x
4 por la segunda fracción x 4 se cancela
y nos queda 2 por x + 2 y del lado
derecho nos queda x + 2 x x 4 que si lo
escribimos de forma desarrollada tenemos
x cuadrada menos 2 x menos 8 ok ahora si
hacemos las multiplicaciones del lado
izquierdo
tenemos 2 x menos 8 2 x + 4 y eso es
igual a x cuadrada menos 2 x menos 8
nuevamente esta es una ecuación
cuadrática así que podemos escribir que
es igual a 0
ahora observen que al sumar 2 x 2 x eso
es igual a 4x y al pasarlo al otro lado
pasa restando así que nos queda bueno x
cuadrada que ya la teníamos
después menos 6x ok y también observen
que del lado izquierdo teníamos menos 84
y eso es igual a menos 4 que al pasar al
otro lado pasa sumando y nos queda menos
4 entonces teníamos 4x que pasó al otro
lado de la igualdad como menos 4x y
también teníamos menos 4 que pasó como
más 4 o que ahora al parecer este es un
problema que no podemos factorizar así
que para conocer las soluciones podemos
usar la fórmula cuadrática que dice que
x es igual a menos b más - la raíz
cuadrada de b cuadrada menos 4 hace
entre 2a y en este caso menos 6 sería b
entonces tenemos menos 6 más menos la
raíz cuadrada de menos 6 al cuadrado
menos 4 por a que es 1 x
qué es 4 y todo eso entre 2 x a y esto
es igual a más 6 más menos la raíz
cuadrada de vamos a ver tenemos 36 más
16 y eso es igual a 52 entre 2
y yo dejaría las soluciones así para no
tener que simplificar las todavía más
entonces nos queda como 6 positivo más
menos la raíz cuadrada de 52 y todo eso
entre 2 y si no han visto la fórmula
cuadrática tenemos otros vídeos con
muchos ejemplos para resolver este tipo
de ecuaciones y bueno esto
definitivamente no será igual a menos 2
ni a 4 así que estas son nuestras dos
soluciones para la ecuación original
hagamos uno más en este problema tenemos
uno entre x más 3 + 1 entre x menos 3
igual a 6 entre x cuadrada menos 9 y en
este caso el mínimo común múltiplo de x
3 x 3 y x cuadrada menos 9 sería
sería bueno miren si factor izamos x
cuadrada menos 9 nos queda x 3 x x 3 ese
es nuestro mínimo común múltiplo y lo
multiplicaremos en ambos lados de la
ecuación entonces del lado izquierdo
vamos a multiplicar lo tal cual es decir
x x + 3 x x menos 3 pero del lado
derecho en lugar de escribirlo como x +
3 por x menos tres vamos a escribirlo
como x cuadrada menos 9 ok entonces al
multiplicar por la primera fracción x 13
cancela y nos queda x menos 3 y en la
segunda fracción x menos trece cancela y
nos queda x + 3 y del lado derecho
simplemente nos queda 6
entonces al sumar x x eso es igual a 2 x
2x es igual a 6 y al dividir ambos lados
entre 2 nos queda que x es igual a 3
pero miren al verificar esta solución es
decir si la sustituimos en la ecuación
original en el denominador de la primera
fracción no hay problema no obtenemos 0
pero si sustituimos x igual a 3 en la
segunda fracción o en lo que tenemos del
lado derecho de la ecuación vamos a
tener 0 en el denominador de las dos
fracciones y si obtenemos 0 en alguna
fracción a eso se le conoce como
solución extraña así que esta ecuación
en realidad no tiene solución es por eso
es que debemos de tener mucho cuidado en
las ecuaciones racionales siempre
regresen a la ecuación original y
sustituyan las soluciones que hayan
obtenido para asegurarse de que no vayan
a dividir entre 0
espero que les sirva